almost since day one I've been telling
you that we are dealing with an actual
virus that spreads virally but we are
also dealing with disinformation that's
spreading virally and ignorant that is
spreading virally and this came to a
head over the weekend with protests
protests of huge groups of people
crowded together mostly without masks
demanding that their states be fully
opened in the middle of a viral pandemic
and they are almost exclusively Trump
supporters not all but mostly Donald
Trump has actually started to be
supportive of them on Twitter and during
press briefings we'll get to that a
little bit later and these are quite
simply actions that are going to spread
the virus and lead to more deaths we're
now starting to see the results of
Wisconsin voting in person and we're
seeing spiked infections in Wisconsin it
takes 10 to 14 days to see that and we
are now seeing it and much the same is
going to happen here so let's take a
brief sort of tour of the country over
the weekend note that Fox News promoted
these as rallies / protests to reopen
the economy with a nice map rather than
as the dangerous mass gatherings that
represent a risk to public health and
indeed these have been chock-full of the
exact type of wacky behavior that you
would expect and imagine much of it
couched under the umbrella of people are
demanding their rights and people are
demanding freedom and so on and so forth
we are putting video up of one of the
protests in Columbus Ohio of course no
surprise filled with Tea Party don't
tread on me flags
also during many of these rallies
including the one in Columbus Ohio no
shortage of anti-semitism someone in a
van stopping with a sign that says the
real plague with a picture of a
stereotypical anti-semitic cartoon and a
Star of David on it it's a nice touch
that at all of this stuff somewhere
there's anti-semitism and often
homophobia as well images from Florida
with signs like live free or die liberty
and freedom now and give me liberty or
give me death and what they're getting
right about this is that indeed this is
an issue of life and death
another young woman protester with a
sign that says no masks my body my
choice Trump 2020 now there have been
both serious and satirical versions of
this sign showing up at different ones
of these protests the irony of the
entire thing of course is that Trump is
against abortion so anybody arguing
about my body my choice when it comes to
the masks but supporting Trump Trump is
okay I guess with forcing someone to
have a kid based on his newfound
anti-abortion position which he learned
at about 68 years old that that was
actually the right position but she'll
be damned if she's going to put on a
surgical mask okay being forced into
having a kid but no surgical masks
whatsoever here's a video from Texas of
a large crowd without masks chanting all
sorts of things including fire foul Chi
and yes if you are watching you will
notice that at least one person in the
crowd is wearing an Alex Jones Infowars
t-shirt not a surprise take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and then here's a video from Brookfield
Wisconsin where you see Trump Pen signs
Naga signs the Tea Party don't tread on
me signs and everything that you would
expect at one of these rallies we have
video from Encinitas California people
with the same tea party flags Trump
signs some they're actually wearing
masks which is interesting but a lot of
the people just looking sort of confused
about what they're even doing and where
they even are conspiracy theorists Alex
Jones also showed up at one of these
rallies it's too dumb to even play video
of it's too predictable to show you
video of but you can find it online and
then last one because this is just
bonkers a woman in the Tony neighborhood
of Huntington Beach California standing
in front of a baskin-robbins ice cream
shop with a sign that says give me
liberty or give me death because of
course anything short of 45 flavors is
indeed slavery so we're in real trouble
here and I I don't want to discount the
reality that if you are one of the 22
plus million people who has lost their
job you are an increase in an
increasingly desperate situation
we've got stimulus money that is being
delivered we have unemployment insurance
enhancements for people who have lost
their jobs and this all has been
weaponized not primarily as an economic
issue but as a political issue as an
issue of freedom and liberty and of the
Constitution and all sorts of other
things that these protesters are
misunderstanding this is about one thing
health risks and Public Health and
Safety there are more good analyses
which suggest the economic impact of the
closures is far smaller than the
economic impact of the virus actually
running rampant
you know how Trump talks about hey if we
had done nothing 2.2 million people
would have died up to 2.2 million and
there would have been potentially
hundreds of millions of people
infected that the economic impact of
that would have been far worse than what
is hopefully the temporary economic
impact of what is being done at least by
some states here now there are a ton of
southern states and others that didn't
have that many cases last week and
they're very quickly becoming hotspots
Ohio at 12,000 cases with more than a
10% increase per day on two consecutive
days if that rate of growth continues
you can have a real problem very very
soon
Texas is growing Florida's growing
Virginia so these are the state's most
likely to reopen the soonest and yet if
this continues these are going to very
rapidly be the states that are worse off
and their economies will suffer as a
result we will what the direction things
are pointing is that we are going to
essentially have waves of overlapping
open and closing for months and months
if not a year without really getting it
under control
if and until we get a working treatment
therapeutic treatment as well as a
vaccine that's what's going to happen if
we have this patchwork of states opening
and closing very often for political
reasons I'm going to devote some time
now to Donald Trump's fomenting of these
very dangerous protests there's a
YouTube channel called up flip that
we're partnering with I would love for
you to check it out I've put the link
right underneath the video make sure to
subscribe to the channel when you're
there up flip is a channel that is all
about exploring small business and what
makes a small business successful every
episode interviews an entrepreneur you
take a tour of the business and these
are not generic interviews you actually
get a really fascinating deep dive into
the history of the business the mistakes
the entrepreneur made what they learned
what motivates them what a day is like
running their business and you get all
sorts of super interesting and valuable
insight about what it's like to run that
type of small business as a business
owner myself I find up flips videos to
be endlessly intriguing even if you
don't own your own business it is really
great for a general audience it's stuff
that I think just about anybody would
find fascinating
and you can check it out by going to
david pakman.com slash up flip the link
is right underneath this video when
you're there make sure to subscribe and
click the bell for notifications